hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et tu tapes le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
oui d'ailleurs on retrouve khadr hier
mathieu qui n'était pas là mathieu
n'était pas là car j'ai fait une
coloscopie je n'ai pas je déconne ça va
bon d'accord mais ça va les honda calme
les images
on rigole ça va non aujourd'hui j'aime
pas qu'on peut être pas là lundi comment
vous savez pourquoi
voilà non non non c'est une vanne sais
pas c'était son but médicaments on dit
la vérité et bayrou a juste dit il a
rendez vous chez le médecin depuis
longtemps et j'ai dit coloscopie c'est
pas ça mais c'est vrai que ça et je vous
dire je ne le savais pas je suis non je
pense à une vanne me suis dit bon voilà
était en pro que toi oui toi c'est vrai
bon bah écoutez allez on va passer on va
le laisser se remettre de ces émotions
là